foreign
a number of bits from the Atlantic
article that had come out and shared
some of the New York Times and part of
our objection was just like with uh the
together trial the results were promote
were were released and promoted in
mainstream media as if they were
scientific findings that everyone could
assess and therefore the fact that they
were out there sort of implies that they
have been assessed by the scientific
Community but there was literally no
paper at all it was there was a there
was a press release I think or you know
maybe just a couple of interviews there
was nothing well that has now changed
kind of so on March 20th just you know
five days ago a couple days after our
last live stream they did and do in dude
hmm
I'm trying that must mean something but
I don't know they did indeed uh post
something to zanotto a pre-print server
although they say they call it a report
and they say quote
um I actually don't have the quote
um they do not intend to publish this
report in a scientific journal
really I wonder why uh well when you
look at the paper you can begin to kind
of see why I have only skimmed it I have
noticed that a lot of other people have
already dug deep and found you know
various various problems with it it's
messy and confusing and pretty long and
and the authors say in their little
Preamble they're not going to publish
this on as a scientific paper like what
does I just give them cover like oh we
put a thing out but well it's not really
the real thing so you know it's just
like it's one faint after another
um and in the near the end of the paper
they say the authors claim that quote
data accumulated since the beginning of
the covid-19 pandemic Point clearly to a
zodiotic origin of SARS Kobe 2.
and then they proceed to make a series
of the weakest arguments I can possibly
imagine I mean it's it's really
remarkable what like the level of
analysis and that they basically don't
expect anyone to check their work like a
they started by not letting anyone check
their work and now they put something
out where they're like yeah but it's not
really a paper We're Not Gonna
um We're Not Gonna submit this to a
journal and yet they make these claims
that just sound like the strongest
claims possible
but the actual claims aren't they're
they're insane well in fact they said
this was the strongest evidence yet for
a zoonotic origin this this like finding
some some bits of raccoon dog genome in
the same place as some SARS Kobe 2.
right some really weak circumstantial
evidence that is actually perfectly
consistent with the idea that the Wuhan
Institute of virology is close enough to
the seafood market that people who work
at one are liable to shop at the other
and we know there were stars Kobe too
there and we know there are raccoon dogs
there so this evidence doesn't give us
anything can do it's not evidence and so
what they are doing and we need a name
for this and I at the moment I don't
have one it's somehow
um
it's like uh headline priming or
headline ginning right the whole idea is
to pretend that there is science that
justifies a headline and that the only
it's a it's a it's a data flow problem
where you know the they're going to put
out the conclusion of the paper and of
course the paper's coming and it will
you know it's basically the bad habit
that uh science folks get into where
they will read the abstract of a paper
and they will not figure out whether the
method section justifies it or the
statistics that were done were correct
or any of those things
um so the idea is you read the abstract
and the whole thing is based on trust
this is like well we're not even going
to give you an abstract what we're going
to give you is the headline you would
write if there was an abstract that was
justified by a paper and then we're not
going to follow up with the paper
because of course the value of the whole
thing is the exercise of producing the
headline and why would you go through
the you know why would you put yourself
at risk of having your headline
invalidated by scrutiny when you could
just allow the headline to float for
good as if a paper had had emerged
um yes this has been going on a long
time by the way yes it has I remember
this from the death of Dolly the sheep
right who was this is going to have been
like late 90s or the odds uh this is
going to be
uh early OTS
and I had a dog in the fight because in
my paper on telomeres I had predicted
that she would die of age-related
pathologies anomalously early and they
said she didn't did they give us a paper
no they said they literally put out a
press release in which they said that
they would do a full necropsy and they
would let us know if they found anything
right which is insane because at the
time that Dolly died she was of course
the oldest mammal clone on Earth and so
a full necropsy doesn't begin to explain
what they should have done for this
animal a they gave the implausible
explanation that they had put it out of
her misery because they couldn't stand
to see her suffer from the pathology
that they swore was not age related
um but you know okay whatever the cause
of death this animal should have been
thin sectioned one end to the other so
that future researchers could go back
and figure out what was taking place
there necropsy is not the beginning of
what they should have done but anyway my
basic point was there was no paper there
either right right this was a case in
which there was a lot at stake a lot
financially at stake because the patent
on nuclear transfer cloning was
incredibly valuable and its value would
be lower if it caused age-related
pathologies so in any case the the trick
of creating a headline or creating an
impression that scientific work has been
reported but not actually presenting the
work is a uh a tactic that one should
expect to see where there's a great deal
at stake either with respect to
something like covet origins or with
respect to something like a valuable uh
patent like nuclear transfer cloning and
um I would also point out that
interestingly that report on raccoon
dogs it came in advance
of the revelation of a paper that Robert
Malone called Smoking Gun on covet
Origins where basically it reported uh
an experiment in which uh this week in
the last four days yeah uh
um last week somehow but I mean you just
said that this the report here predated
the headline the initial report in which
we all got the word that something
important had happened with raccoon dogs
right preceded by less than a week the
revelation of this published work in
which the enhancement of uh SARS like
coves to become infective of humans was
discovered in the literature so anyway
check out Robert Malone's Twitter and
search for the term Smoking Gun and you
will find that
that research
I'm reminded you can show my screen just
briefly
um this is a article published in Forbes
in 2020 uh in July 2020 in which they
say you must not do your own research
when it comes to science
and they make they make this argument
that it's just too tough It's too
challenging and you're putting yourself
and everyone else at risk by doing so
then compare that to Zach if you would
give me my screen back for a moment so I
can show
this paper you can now now bring up this
this is this is the report that they say
is not destined for a
for a journal
in which they make introductory remarks
and say among other things
uh
no they say somewhere in here that they
are not going to submit this to a
journal but uh this paper
is oh this report is not intended for
publication in a journal there it is
um they're keep they start with key
points which is sometimes done in an
actual scientific paper but this is
accessible if they would share more
information the likes of which you're
supposed to do in science and
to have this kind of analysis happening
at the same time as granted that Forbes
article is from almost three years ago
but throughout this we've been told
don't ask questions don't do your own
research don't assess for yourself
simply trust the authorities who've
shown up with credentials that you may
or may not be able to assess with
backgrounds and with skills that you may
not be able to assess and don't you know
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain pay no attention to the fact
that the entire system has been so so
corrupted by the role of money and
federal granting agencies that the vast
majority of people who are now doing
science in the west at least in the U.S
are doing little tiny reductionist
pieces of Science and will actually say
if you ask them questions outside of
their little domain well that's not my
concern so why would we trust you know
World Health to people who will say no I
just do this thing I just do this little
thing and when you go looking I spend a
little bit of time looking at the
backgrounds of a few of these authors
who you know aren't aren't the ones that
we keep on hearing about and indeed
they're just they're just doing this
narrow you know blinders on science for
their entire careers and where's the
evidence that they actually know how to
assess things I don't find it no and
clearly clearly they don't for them to
put their name to this
um
clearly they don't uphold any such
standard and I will point out so much of
this
uh so much of the malfeasance here come
down to the application of two different
standards depending upon whether you're
on narrative or off narrative right
almost all of this the things that
people who are dissidents are accused of
violating the sacred rules of science
the fact is those who are on narrative
are granted no end of leeway in the same
direction so
if you were to Simply apply any
consistent standard you would come out
with a far better answer than we have
and in fact what's happening is you know
somebody is peeking at who it is who is
engaged in work and deciding whether to
Institute an impossible standard that
can't be met or no standard at all so
that you will meet it irrespective of
whether what you've effectively done is
published a newspaper headline without a
method
um and anyway uh of course this crashes
the world right science is not capable
of you know science isn't a posture it's
not a costume right it's also not
optional right and we've taken it for
optional it's like it's it's an
affectation for many people who are
columns of scientists yeah you actually
have to do the method correctly and you
have to do it according to the
underlying philosophy of science where
it doesn't work yeah right the fact that
it involves sciency looking stuff or
science sciencey language has nothing to
do with it people with degrees it
doesn't matter you either did the method
right or you didn't yeah
yeah as long as we spend a little bit of
time here
um let me just
let me just provide some of their
evidence for their incredibly strong
claim so you can show my screen again
here Zach this is again from the report
um purporting to show the strongest
evidence uh yet that uh sorry Kobe 2 had
a zoonotic origin data accumulated since
the beginning of the covid-19 pandemic
Point clearly towards a zoonotic origin
of SARS Kobe too oh
one a preponderance of the earliest
hospitalized covid-19 patients were
linked to a single location
really two the locations of early severe
Copa 19 cases without a clear
epidemiological link to the market to
the Hanan Market nevertheless we're so
centered on and close to the market it
is clear that Community transmission of
starscovy 2 begin in this local area and
only later expand across Wuhan
incredible incredible of course depends
on a correct start date for the pandemic
oh yeah and they they're definitely
sticking with January you know
january-ish in this paper nonsense and
it you know it just it's it's all about
the location
almost all of their pieces of evidence
here these strong overwhelming evidence
and then let me just uh
finish with these arguments stand in
stark contrast to the absence of
evidence for any other SARS Covington
absence of evidence that's fascinating
even in the Genome of the thing
here here's what they're doing yeah
right
a
this couldn't possibly convince anybody
who's paying attention in detail right
so the purpose of this is to convince
people who are not paying attention that
something has happened that has swung
the pendulum in the direction of natural
origin right yep so
and there's a vast number of people in
that category right these are people who
are you know glued to their New York
Times and haven't understood that it is
a propaganda arm of the government and
who knows what else right these are
people who just need the headline itself
and so the idea that there is like this
cottage industry of generating headlines
that serve the right people's interests
and cause some large percentage of the
audience that isn't doing its own
research in any regard to jump well it
feels like this report not even a
pre-print right because they say they're
not gonna
um
submit it to a journal seems like this
report those bits that I just read are
actually written to be pulled and quoted
by the mainstream media right like this
is not written for scientists it's
written for the media to do pull quotes
and you know I don't I don't know that's
that's a hypothesis it's written but it
doesn't feel that that that little
bracketed argument that I just read part
of
I I cannot remember as as bad as a
scientific literature is I cannot
remember ever seeing anything so
transparently flimsy in the discussion
section which is what that would more or
less be of an actual scientific paper it
actually is the uh private citizen
analog of you know the uh busy scientist
reading abstracts right there is a
citizen that just pays attention to what
the New York Times has concluded right
oh natural origin strongest evidence yet
why that does sound strong on top of
already strong evidence right and what
you what's that you say there's no
evidence at all for a laboratory origin
fascinating geez I wonder what those
people one side we've got evidence and
on the other side we have no evidence
right and I know which side I like yep
and so you know we certainly saw this
with Ivermectin together trial six
months of looking at a slide from a
presentation without a method and then
when you get the method is of course uh
fraudulent and caps the dosage this is a
trick right the trick the purpose of the
trick is in the New York Times right
it's not to convince anybody who
understands science who is paying
attention to the evidence because it
couldn't it's too thin it doesn't there
is no evidence here right and combine
that with articles like in Forbes in
2020 saying when it comes to the science
do not do your own research right like
really that is that that is literally
the argument coming across the
Transcendent people it is your it is
your civic responsibility to accept what
we say and I would argue and we have
argued many times it's actually your
civic responsibility to do no such thing
it is your civic responsibility to do
the opposite at the point that they tell
you is your civic responsibility just
accept what we say you need to say
actually now I will not yeah not you are
you are inherently wrong because you
said that but now I will explicitly ask
for all of the evidence that you have
laid out in as clear terms as possible
so that I can assess and most of the
people who are being chastised for doing
their own research aren't doing their
own research per se what they're doing
is listening to unsanctioned channels
where people like you and me who did
study biology you know have the relevant
degrees not only a biology degree but
evolutionary biology which is highly
relevant to many different facets of
what unfolded under covid like listening
to us and figuring out whether we're
making sense is a totally reasonable
thing for somebody who does not believe
that they have the toolkit to do the
analysis themselves to do right and then
how would you know if you're being
suckered gee I don't know track record
would that do it right the point is
they're trying to Spook people they're
trying to Poison the Well of well what
would you do if you didn't trust the
official narrative
maybe I would listen to people who work
you know well qualified and also didn't
trust the official narrative see what
they have to say and if they turn out to
be wrong across the board okay maybe
they're not good at it but if they turn
out to be right across the board I'm not
going to make excuses over it
[Music]